o trabalho de uma das profissões mais
antigas do mundo
não é aquela profissão é eu sou
astrônomo tá
e apesar de ser uma profissão muito
antiga é tem muita gente que não sabe o
que é astronomia o que os astrônomos
fazem um desafio aqui quer falar pra
vocês
em alguns minutos mais de 10 mil anos de
história
então a astronomia é tão antigo quanto
você olhar para o céu e todos os nossos
antepassados faziam isso e o que eles
percebiam lá no início da humanidade é
que é um monte de coisas no céu eles não
sabiam que era aquilo ou como que não
foi parar lá em cima mas ele perceber
algumas coisas desde o início que a
aparência do céu muda noite após noite o
movimento da lua e do sol do planeta das
estrelas seguiam os padrões
então eles começaram a perceber isso e
começar a construir grandes monumentos
né que serviam para eles ficarem
acompanhando o movimento dos astros
então nós temos em todas as culturas
antigas do mundo grandes monumentos e
são na verdade grandes calendários tá
stone range chipping it's a machu picchu
pirâmides do egito são na verdade
grandes observatórios astronômicos que
foram construídos pelos povos antigos
para registrar a passagem do tempo e
saber também o início das estações do
ano graças à construção desses momentos
que o homem conseguiu começar a se
planejar né possui seus primeiros
calendários ea partir daí conseguir
planejar sua agricultura
então a agricultura foi a primeira
grande conquista humana foi aquilo que
permite o homem deixar de ser um caçador
nômade e passar a se estabelecer em
cidades na revolução agrícola que só
pode acontecer com a invenção do
calendário a partir da observação dos
astros marcou o início da nossa
civilização
naquela época o pessoal também
acreditava umas coisas bem estranhas
como por exemplo é a posição dos
planetas afeta a nossa vida aqui na
terra
a astrologia que é que prega
ea astronomia que a ciência que estuda o
universo lá no passado era a mesma coisa
todos os grandes astrônomos o passado
eram astrólogos também então eles
construíam esses observatório também
para medir né a posição dos planetas e
tentar entender como ele se movimenta no
céu para que eles pudessem prever o
futuro onde eles estariam e fazer
previsões que nunca davam certo então te
cobrar e o copérnico que é ptolomeu
todos eles eram astrólogos
mas esse trabalho deles teve uma
importância muito grande porque com a
terra no centro do universo eles não
conseguiam prever onde os planetas vão
ficar no futuro quando chegou o
copérnico ele fez uma uma proposta muito
ousada falou olha não está funcionando o
modelo da terra no centro do universo
vamos colocar então a terra em torno do
sol uma ideia muito usada mas que fez
funcionar então as previsões planetárias
só que essa proposta do copérnico
precisava de uma comprovação e refutável
algo que realmente não dessa imagem as
dúvidas de quem proporcionou isso foi o
galileu galilei galileu não inventou o
telescópio mas ele foi o primeiro a
apontar o telescópio para o céu e
descobrir coisas que ninguém imaginava
ele descobriu que a lua não era uma
esfera perfeita de cristal mas que era
cheia de buracos vales montanhas
crateras assim como a terra descobriu
que o sol era cheio de manchas e também
viu que em torno do planeta júpiter que
algumas estrelinhas que ficavam mudando
de posição
aquilo foi a comprovação que a idéia de
copérnico tava certa nem tudo girava em
torno da terra
o centro estava no sol e não no nosso
planeta
essa foi a primeira grande lição de
humildade que astronomia nos ensinou
luciano do centro do universo
o telescópio acho que foi a invenção que
mais mudou a idéia da humanidade a
história da humanidade
com ele a gente descobrir novos mundos
planeta urano o planeta netuno foram
descobertos depois da invenção do
telescópio e o número de estrelas que a
gente conhece passou de algumas milhares
para centenas e centenas de milhões
são tantas que hoje a gente nem chama
mais elas pelo nome 5 somente para o
número de catálogo
com a idade moderna e chegarão novas
conquistas tecnológicas ea sua mina
ficou cada vez mais complexa
foram construídos três cópias cada vez
maiores que deixaram de ficar nas
sacadas dos cientistas os observatórios
no centro da cidade e ir pro alto de
montanhas isolados processados unidos na
montanha da califórnia
lá no comecinho do século passado foi
construído o maior telescópio do mundo
na época o retorno do monte wilson com
espelho de dois metros e quarenta
centímetros de diâmetro
neste espelho os astrônomos puderam
fazer as observações que eu mudar mais
uma vez o nosso lugar no universo
quem participou disso foi esse
cavalheiro da foto é derrubam o mesmo
que deu nome ao telescópio espacial o
hubble estava interessado em estudar um
tipo de objeto que é tava intrigando os
astrônomos as chamadas nebulosas
espirais havia uma é bem conhecida que
era essa chamada nebulosa de andrômeda e
um roubo ficou estudando para tentar
saber a que distância que ela estava da
gente e o que ele descobriu foi uma
coisa que chocou todo mundo ele
descobriu que essa nebulosa na verdade
era uma nebulosa na nossa galáxia
mas uma outra galáxia até maior do que a
nossa via láctea estava distante há
milhões de anos luz daqui do dia pra
noite o hubble multiplicou o tamanho do
universo por ordem de grandeza
foi uma verdadeira revolução e as
descobertas que ele fez não pararam aí
ele descobriu que todas as outras
galáxias do universo então se afastando
umas das outras ou seja um universo está
em expansão e se ele está se expandindo
isso quer dizer que lá no passado essas
coisas estavam todas juntas ou seja um
universo teve um começo a nossa história
teve o nosso começo que foi o big bang
então essa foi a segunda lição de
humildade castro - eu pra gente não
tirou o primeiro centro do universo e
depois mostrou que a nossa galáxia é uma
entre bilhões e bilhões de outras
os astrônomos não precisarão desenvolver
equipamentos para chegar cada vez mais
fundo buscando essas perguntas que eles
fazem uma das coisas que vocês usam
todos os dias e está todo mundo usando
hoje aqui nessa as câmeras digitais
as câmeras digitais
foram construídas pelos astrônomos para
tentar pegar cada fóton que chega lá das
galáxias mais distantes depois de
viajarem milhões e milhões de anos antes
de chegarem aqui na terra é então essa é
uma das maiores câmaras que existem no
mundo afirmou megan ela tem 244
megapixels e é melhor que uma tepco e
aqui dá é muito muito sensível e fica
muito mais longe do que o homem consegue
enxergar
então apesar da astronomia às vezes
parecia não ter utilidade imediata tudo
aqui toda a tecnologia é desenvolvida
para o astrônomo conseguir responder às
suas perguntas chega eventualmente a ao
cidadão comum
então lembre-se dos astrônomos conselho
for tirar uma self que a câmera foi eles
que inventaram os astronautas também
desenvolveram vários outros tipos de
telescópios para enxergar além daquilo
que o nosso onde percebe
nós enxergamos somente uma pequena
fração da luz na chamada luz visível mas
nós não chegamos em ondas de rádio em
infravermelho hi-fi seta hoje a
astronomia é feita em todos os domínios
do chamado espectro eletromagnético
todos os tipos de luz é então os
astrônomos constroem observatórios que
enxergam o universo em toda a sua cor é
tanto aqui em terra quanto no espaço os
impedimentos de astronomia hoje em dia
são empreendimentos multinacionais
bilionários que vão construir
instrumentos de ponta que custam muito
muito dinheiro e que se não ficar
operando o tempo todo e isso requer
pessoas muito especializadas e o local
disso tem que ser construído tem que ser
muito especial também
geralmente isso vai ficar no alto de
montanhas muito isolados no meio do
deserto ou no topo de vulcões e hoje em
dia a gente está querendo respondeu que
as perguntas que têm perturbado o ser
humano desde o seu início
de onde viemos para onde vamos
será que estamos sós no universo onde a
gente acredita que estamos próximos de
começar a responder essas perguntas com
os segmentos que estão ou ficar prontos
na próxima década
esse aqui vai ser o maior telescópio do
mundo o telescópio extremamente grande
o espelho dele tem 40 metros de diâmetro
aproximadamente é quase
é uma quadra de basquete de diâmetro só
o espelho mec tem o tamanho dele
comparado aos carros vocês terem uma
idéia então os instrumentos da próxima
década
a gente acredita que vamos conseguir em
começar a responder essas perguntas
mas esse é o grande barato da ciência e
da astronomia
para cada pergunta que você consegue
responder aparece muitas outras que a
gente nem pensou em perguntar antes
então astronomia né é a verdadeira busca
dos porquês mesmo que você não queira
buscar porque ele aparece pra você
responder às pessoas que não sabem que o
astrônomo elas ficam pensando poxa mais
você só trabalha de noite né você você
fica a semana uma montanha nela se essa
ideia da sony é uma pessoa meio reclusa
que fica no topo da montanha lá isolado
mas acreditem a maior parte dos meus
colegas não é nada disso
o astrônomo hoje em dia ele passa a
maior parte do tempo na frente do
computador mesmo ou fazendo complicadas
contas cálculos para explicar é o que
está acontecendo ou então analisando os
dados e as imagens dos telescópios que
que estão por aí disponíveis mas o que a
gente gosta mesmo é de poder para o
local bem escuro e ficar olhando o céu
né social que a gente conta de uma praia
deserta ou céu que tem numa fazenda a
gente fica olhando esse céu estrelado e
fica pensando naquilo que inspirou a
gente desde o início a seguir essa
carreira problema que está cada vez mais
difícil de fazer porque na cidade é o
que a gente encontra isso né
a nossa noite está acabando é o celta
cada vez mais claro e isso é um problema
não só para a astronomia mas por uma
série de outras coisas também é todo
mundo gosta de uma cidade bem iluminada
é isso dá uma sensação de segurança mas
a iluminação mal planejada
quando você ilumina o céu ao invés da
terra ela é na verdade o desperdício de
energia
um desperdício de dinheiro é o que a
gente chama de poluição luminosa
então isso né tem claro impactado as
observações astronômicas mas tem um dano
muito maior que você está removendo das
pessoas com
imponente da cultura humana que existe
desde que o homem é homem
a gente sabe que mais da metade da
população mundial nunca viu a via láctea
nessa faixa de estrelas que a gente
consegue ver no céu se você tiver um
local escuro
então quando você remove isso da sua da
sua essência
você tá matando algo que inspirou muitas
gerações passadas
vocês acham por exemplo que o van gogh e
é conseguir pintar as noites estreladas
do ródano se ele não tivesse visto as
estrelas ou que olavo bilac e é
conseguir compor
ora direis ouvir estrelas no meio da
cidade de são paulo o que o joão
pernambuco e é conseguir compô-la do
sertão se ele não consegue nem ver a luz
da lua é então a astronomia o céu tem
uma conexão que é muito profunda conosco
então a gente tem que tomar cuidado que
a gente não pode perder isso faz parte
da própria humanidade eo legal da
astronomia isso né ela tem conexões com
a nossa cultura mas tem uma conexão que
ainda mais íntima é porque vocês já
devem ter ouvido falar que nós somos
feitos de poeira de estrelas
parece clichê mas é a mais pura verdade
cada átomo que tem nessa sala ele teve
alguma vez já no passado no interior de
uma estrela estrelas muito maiores que o
sol que viveram antes mesmo do da terra
existir explodiram e dar origem ao que a
gente tem aqui então carbono da madeira
aqui do piso dessa sala o oxigênio que
você está respirando o cálcio dos seus
ossos isso tudo tudo tudo é matéria
estelar reciclada que teve existe há já
muito tempo antes do próprio sol nascer
então essa é uma realidade assim como
tem coisas que são mais antigas ainda
que foram surgiram justamente no big
bang
no início do universo o hidrogênio que
compõem a molécula da água que a gente
bebe o hélio que enche o balãozinho da
festa de aniversário eo lítio que está
na bateria do seu celular
são remanescentes sair do evento que deu
origem ao nosso universo
então a gente tem uma conexão que é
muito profunda com o céu e essa acho que
é a principal lição que a astronomia
traz pra gente é uma coisa que é muito
profunda que às vezes pode até meio
deprimente que você
vai pensar poxa eu só nessa um ser
humano que está uma pedrinha girando em
torno de uma estrela bem ordinária na
periferia de uma galáxia que é uma
galáxia que é igual a centenas de outras
bilhões de galáxias do universo mas ao
mesmo tempo tudo aquilo que compõem esse
universo inimaginavelmente grande está
dentro de nós também
da próxima vez que você olhar para o céu
não pense você vai pro céu quando você
morrer porque a gente já está no céu
o céu é aqui obrigado